[Music]
so you run a company
let's say you sell picture frames you
built this business from the ground up
you offer your local community jobs
things are going great until one day a
certain senator bought one of your
picture frames
and when he hung it up it fell on his
toe putting him into the fetal position
resentful against her picture frame
company after all he is a noble
prestigious u.s senator
he has a staffer strapped up a bill that
would effectively put you out of
business
eventually war gets back to you about
this new bill you read the bill online
and panic
is this the end of the business you
worked so hard to create well when the
government threatens your business like
this
you have four options number one you can
curl up in the fetal position like the
senator and hope it goes away
number two you can throw your hands up
in the air and say oh well
i guess i'll just close up shop you're
all fired number three you can move to
capitol hill yourself to rant and rave
to anyone willing to listen about how
this bill is a terrible idea
or you have option number four you can
focus on what you do best making picture
frames and hire a lobbyist in dc to do
the work for you
although curling up in the fetal
position does sound appealing
you decide to go with option number four
so what kind of lobbyists are you gonna
hire
are you gonna hire the dry bland by the
book nerdy lobbyist that no one in dc is
excited to see or talk to
how about the lobbyist that has a buddy
buddy relationship with the senator
going after you
they play golf together they're on a
first name basis with each other
that sounds like a much better option so
boom
you just turned into a special interest
group that just hired the first lobbyist
although this is a ridiculous example
this whole process is exactly why
lobbying has grown into a 3.5 billion
dollar industry
an industry that people perceive to be
as slimy as it gets second only to the
politicians they
legally bribe so how does this world of
legal bribes work
let's find out lobbying is about
foresight
but anticipating your opponent's moves
congress is completely for sale
[Music]
now if you're a business owner that's
getting picked on by the government or
you're just looking to collect those fat
paychecks as a lobbyist
or you're the kind of person that
watches videos like this
you're obviously an ambitious
hard-working person and as someone who
has big goals when you're working all
the time it's hard not to eat like a pig
and work out
the problem with people like us is that
no matter the goals we accomplish
if we're unhealthy don't have any energy
or we end up dying early
none of this matters but fear not
because i have the solution
built bar build bars are by far the best
tasting protein bars out there
and this is coming from personal
experience instead of tasting like
you're eating mud wrapped in plastic
i'm actually excited to eat them like
any regular snack they have over 57
000 reviews a ton of different flavors
at least 17 grams of protein per bar
low sugar gluten free low calorie count
basically they beat out all their
competitors in almost every single
aspect while tasting the best
it is to die for i had a shoe i eat
these when i need a break from work when
i go to train jiu jitsu and i absolutely
love them
so when they reached out to sponsored
this video i knew i had to share this
healthy deliciousness with you guys
and for a limited time buildbar is
offering you guys 20 off your first
purchase when you go to buildbar.com and
use code jaketran20
so take care of that one second meet you
get in this light by pausing the video
and going to buildbar.com with the code
jake trend 20 with the link in the video
description
[Music]
like the example we went over the main
reason why people hired lobbyists is to
get the government to stop doing
something
or to get the government to do something
that would benefit them this could be to
keep the government from harming your
business
like how big tech spent nearly half a
billion dollars on lobbying in the past
decade
or it could be foreign powers wanting to
get their foot in the door with
important politicians in capitol hill
they hire lobbyists to make that
introduction those same foreign powers
might want lobbyists to keep the us from
messing with their economy there are
also unions and coalitions of all sorts
that want to protect their interests
from the government
those same unions corporations and
individuals also use lobbyists to go
after government handouts
and my personal favor you can use the
government to get an advantage over your
competitors
like amazon who pushed for a higher
minimum wage in the name of workers
rights
when they were really automating their
low wage jobs with robots anyways and
wanted to squeeze their competitors and
so
effective november 1st we are also
establishing a new amazon minimum wage
of 15 an hour
[Applause]
who does amazon pay to do this that's
right lobbyists
we have an entire video on this exact
subject of crony capitalism linked in
the description
whatever the reason is this is why
lobbying is so big
and if you're wondering why a person
would want to be a slimy lobbyist in the
first place
well the idea of getting the government
off the people's backs or getting the
government to help people can sound
appealing to some people
and the potential for fat paychecks is
also nice if you decide to hire
lobbyists be prepared to pay because the
top lobbying firms can charge as much as
50 000
per month and since you're probably not
going to see results right away that
monthly retainer is gonna add up
the most notorious lobbyist jack
abramoff charge each client as high as
180 thousand dollars a month
that's over two million dollars if just
one client stays for a year
so let's say you want to make that kind
of money as a lobbyist or you want to
hire one yourself
what exactly do they do power is a lot
like real estate it's all about location
location location closer you are to the
source
the higher your property value in
business people sell goods and services
in dc lobbyists sell ideas not just any
ideas but the ideas their clients want
them to sell
your clients are outsourcing influence
into your hands
our system of politicians is made up of
just that humans
and humans can be weak and corruptable
so that's what we prey on
contrary to popular belief lobbies
really ever just barge into a room slap
a bunch of cash on the desk and call it
a day
no for the most part politicians today
can't risk getting exposed and going to
prison for taking direct bribes
so selling ideas takes a more subtle
psychological approach
in fact if you do it right politicians
will never even realize they're being
legally bribed
it just doesn't work that way natural
like human nature
says that i'm gonna be more willing to
help you out
if i view you as a friend and if i view
as a partner the last thing you want to
do is scream and yell at these
politicians about how if you don't
support this bill
you're evil and gonna go hell why
because there's a difference between
being heard
and being agreed with it goes against
human nature if someone is screaming at
you
calling you names would you want to
listen to them and for somebody to come
in
and tell somebody hey what to do and to
say it's my way or the highway
it gets such a negative reaction from
members of congress
but at the same time the conversation is
almost never just give me a hundred
thousand dollars and i'll vote this way
we can make this problem go away before
it becomes a more expensive problem
are you trying to solicit a bribe
for me it's more of a friend doing a
friend of favor kind of thing
here's what that notorious lobbyist jack
abramoff had to say about it
normally there's never a conversation
like that
there's i'm your friend you're my friend
what do you need you know oh well i'm
trying to raise
a million dollars uh to make sure i get
reelected
okay i'll i'll take care of 300 000 i'll
throw a fundraiser don't worry about it
uh okay great jack what do you need well
i've got clients
that got these interests oh i think i
can be helpful in that that's the
discussion
no matter who you are if someone does
something for you without asking
you're gonna be compelled to return the
favor in order to maintain your
self-image as a fair just person
that is what you're betting on to sway
politicians in your client's favor
jack abramoff's guilty plea to charges
of tax evasion conspiracy and fraud
could spell
trouble for some of washington's top
power brokers
on january 2006 jack abramoff was
sentenced to six years in federal prison
for conspiracy to bribe public officials
tax evasion and mail fraud
jack and his friends charged their
native american tribe clients an
estimated 85 million dollars
a royal rip-off they were accused of
secretly splitting multi-million dollar
profits
illegally giving gifts and campaign
donations in exchange for votes and
legislation
and they were even accused of secretly
lobbying against their own clients
in order to get them to pay more money
to them to combat this perceived threat
pretty clever jack paid over a million
dollars per year for four sky boxes at
major sports arenas to entertain his
political friends in return for favors
he also co-owned a fancy restaurant
called signatures which in my mind
conjures up images of that generic store
brand signature select
as another place to take his political
friends to lavish them with expensive
meals
he even paid for multiple golfing trips
of scotland for a few politicians
needless to say when all this
information came out jack became the
poster child for everything wrong with
big money and politics
much like how martin shrelly became the
poster child for everything wrong with
big pharma
the problem is if he was the biggest and
most evil person in dc
when he finally went to prison why
didn't corruption end
kind of like how only one banker went to
jail for the 2008 financial crisis
the lobbying culture mixes money and
power and that can be dangerous
but is abram off an exception or is he
just a lobbyist who figured out a way to
game the system
and then got caught sure we had someone
to crucify and blame
reforms were passed but those same
reforms were written by the very people
it was trying to regulate
so if jack wasn't the problem if reforms
didn't fix anything
then what is the cure
[Music]
everyone cringes at the thought of dirty
special interest groups and lobbyists
but are they the only problem are they
the only ones in washington with special
interests
after all the only thing that gives
these evil lobbyists any power
the only thing that allows them to
charge 50 000 per month the only thing
that motivates good and bad special
interest groups to dump money into
capitol hill
is because of the simple fact that
politicians have power to be bought in
the first place
going back to that first example of the
picture frame company that a senator
really just wanted to take down
who's at fault who is the amore one the
picture frame company trying to stay in
business by hiring a lobbyist
the lobbyist for being friends with
politicians that can save the business
or the politicians themselves for
starting this whole transaction in the
first place
the bigger the government gets the more
potential for corruption there is
and the more potential for corruption
there is to be bought the more lobbyists
will be lining up to collect that
monthly retainer
and if you think that's true the more
powerful the government the more
corruption there is to be bought
then shouldn't the blame fall at least
partially on us for giving these
politicians this much power to begin
with
now there is a valid argument that
politicians need at least some power to
stop industries from polluting
to keep things like the tobacco industry
in check which is valid
just know that if you believe in that
you're gonna have to accept that big
money will always be a part of big
[Music]
politics
the biggest lobbying group in dc is the
u.s chamber of commerce
which spent a nice 77 million dollars in
2019 alone
now to be clear the u.s chamber of
commerce is not a branch of the us
government even though it sounds like
one
very clever branding if you ask me with
the next biggest spinner being the open
society policy center which spent 48
million dollars in 2019
third place belongs to the national
association of realtors then big pharma
and if we go down the list a little more
we have amazon in 9th place with
facebook right behind it in 10th place
and google in 19th place at almost 13
million dollars
not surprising being that those big tech
giants have all faced many severe
threats from capitol hill over the years
now these may sound like huge unfair
numbers that the common man would never
be able to compete with but as we talked
about earlier how much of this is on us
there are around 200 million adults in
the us take away 10
of the 200 million for less fortunate
people and you're left with 180 million
adults
now unless you're living on the streets
you can probably afford to donate one
dollar
a year to causes or lobbying groups that
fight for your special interests
you know what i take that back because
beggars on the streets can actually make
a ton of tax-free money
i just begged for an hour but i did well
if i did this for an eight-hour day i
would have made 90 bucks
23 foul for a year
tax-free but i digress if 180 million
adults donated one dollar to lobbyists
of their choice per year
not per month that's 180 million dollars
putting the people at the top of the
biggest spenders list
in fact the people will spend nearly as
much as the top four biggest lobbyists
combined
rockefeller is often remembered as the
richest man in history
the king of the greedy capitalist pigs
yes since he got his first job as a
broke 16 year old after spending 6 weeks
searching for one
which he would celebrate as job day one
thing he always made time for no matter
how broke he was
was charitable giving when i was only
making a dollar a day
rockefeller later recalled i was giving
away 5 10 or 25 cents
can you say the same for yourself i know
i can't so before you go complaining
about how big corporations rule the
world how
unfair life is just remember the
solution might just be inside your
wallet
now typically this is where i would
enthusiastically tell you guys to
subscribe and turn on the notification
bell for more video essays just like
this one on the most thought provoking
things in business
which you should absolutely do but
people all over youtube have long been
reporting how
unreliable the notification bell is
including people subscribed to this
channel
so if you want to be the first to watch
new video essays we put out or if you
want to fight to get that first comment
on new videos
or you just want a wait for me to reach
out to you if something were to ever
happen to this channel
you can join the inbox notification
squad you'll get notified right in your
email as soon as new videos launch
you'll also get weekly writings in the
near future with no spam and no selling
of your information
so pause the video and take 10 seconds
to join the inbox notification squad by
going to jtrend.ioslash email with the
link below
and you might as well click that
subscribe button while you're down there
too that's jaketrain.io
email with the link below and check out
the sponsor of this video too
to the glorious watch the end club where
we get a little bit more personal a
little bit more like face to face
if you want behind the scenes stuff and
day in the life kind of stuff and that
kind of thing you can follow me on
instagram and join.io
that is enough shameless plugs for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome
ivan jake i'll see you guys in the next
one oh yeah stay dangerous
stay dangerous and i'll see you guys in
the next one
[Music]
you